Scientists have discovered the remains
of 15 partial skeletons in a burial
chamber and South Africa, which they
believe is a new type of species of human.
It has been named the lady. The time in
which you live is not yet known fully.
Those scientists estimate that it
was around 3 million years ago,
meaning it is an important link in the
structure of the human family tree.
The remains discovered was tell us a
lot about our ancestors here and because
there are 15 different
individual specimens,
we will have a large amount to learn.
Homeowner Letty is believed to have been
small brain based off the size of its
skull.
However,
it was clearly capable of the ritual
behavior of burying their dead.
This is a remarkable fine as this was
something that was believed to have been
unique to humans of the modern time.
Scientists are now fully aware that there
is much more to learn and now this is
a creature that may change how we think
about ourselves even today as modern
humans. For more videos about
science in many other subjects.
I want to invite you to subscribe
and check out my channel.
Thank you for watching.